[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد بعد طول انتظار واصرار
مقاتلات الاف 16 ستنضم لسلاح الجو
الاوكراني كبديلا عن الطائرات السوفياتيه
خطوه ستشكل نقطه تحول فارقه في وتيره
الدعم الغربي
وايضا في مسار الحرب في عامها الثاني تغير
واضح في موقف الاداره الامريكيه فبعد
تحفظها على ملف 16 وافقت اداره رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن على برامج تدريب
للطيارين الاوكرانيين على المقاتلات
المفضله لدى الحلفاء
لمميزاتها القتاليه العاليه والمتطوره هذا
القرار الامريكي اعتبر بانه رساله لروسيا
مفادها بان واشنطن لن تسمح بهزيمه
اوكرانيا ولن تتردد في تقديمه الاسلحه
المتطوره لتحقيق انجازات عسكريه عدد ارض
كاف وعدت واشنطن بعدم استخدام المقاتلات
لتنفيذ ضربات جويه في العمق الروسي دون
شبه جزيره القرم التي يمكن تحول لبؤره
مواجهه وتوتر ساخن خصوصا وان واشنطن لم
تضع قيودا بشانها طبعا موسكو لم تتاخر في
الرد على هذه الخطوه الامريكيه حيث اعتبر
سفيرها لدى الولايات المتحده بان القرار
الامريكي عبسي كما اسماه وبان ارسال
مقاتلات افسد عشر الى كاف لن يقوض اهداف
روسيا العسكريه بل يثير تساؤلات عن ضلوع
حلف الناتو في الصرع ومدى قدره كاب على
استخدامها اوروبا سمنت هذه الخطوه بل
اعتبرها بورين بانها ستساهم في اعطاء مسار
مختلف كما اسماه المعارك
[موسيقى]
تقدم الضوء الاخضر لتسليم مقاتلات اف 16
للجيش الاوكراني بعد تزايد الضغوط عليها
هل ستغير المقاتلات ميزان القوى
المقاتلات ستساهم في تعزيز المجال الجوي
الاوكراني وحمايه البنيه التحتيه وصد
الهجمات الروسيه المكثفه المقاتلات ترصد
اهدافها بدقه في جميع الظروف لها القدره
على استكشاف الطائرات المعاديه
واشنطن رفضت تقديم المقاتلات خوفا من
تسريب التكنولوجيا التي تعمل بها الى
موسكو ديميترو كوليبا وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه هناك حاجه لتطوير السلاح الجو
الاوكراني لصد الغارات الروسيه
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من موسكو
الدبلوماس هو السابقه اهلا بك من واشنطن
الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في شؤون
السياسيه الامريكيه اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام
واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من واشنطن معك دكتور
عقيل حديث واشنطن عن ارسال مدربين لطيارين
قادرين على ان يقودوا الابسه عشر هل هو
تصريح رسمي
بالبدء بالاجراءات لتمكين اكياس من الاف
شكرا لك على هذه
الكريم الموسكو
نقرا الامريكي
مصادر غربيه اخرى وبدا ارسال او على الاقل
قالوا في الاسابيع القليله المقبله ستبدا
ستبدا عمليات التدريبات تدريبات معقده
صعبه على هذه الطائره منظومه شديده
التداخل في العاده تحتاج عاما كاملا لكن
اعتقد بسبب
دكتور عقيل حتى حتى سنتين يعني البعض يقول
بانه قياده صخور قياده الملك تختلف تماما
عن الاف 16 التي يجب ان يكون طيارها متمكن
لقيادتها لدقتها لتعقيداتها الى اخره
يعني هو يمكن اختصارها الى اشهر حتى في
بعض الاحيان اذا كان الطيارون يمتلكون
المهارات الاساسيه اللازمه لياقات البدنيه
اختبارات الصحيه يتجاوزونها ويتمكنون من
اللغه الانجليزيه يعني الطيران العراقيون
الذين دربوا على الابس 16 في الولايات
المتحده استغرقوا ثلاث سنوات تختلف من
سياق الى سياق لكنه في العاده من عام الى
عامين يمكن اختصارها هذا تطور استراتيجي
حقيقه لصالح او
كرانيا الذي نشهده منذ البدايه منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب انه اوكرانيا كانت لديها اسلحه
روسيه عموما معظم الاسلحه الجيش اذا كانت
روسيه وتدريجيا ولكن على نحو متسارع تم
استبدال هذه الاسلحه باسلحه غربيه بعد ان
استنفذت اوكرانيا الاسلحه الروسيه اخذتها
من بولندا واخذ
تها الاساسيه
مستبعد تماما في الواقع دكتور عقيل تتذكر
معنا حضرتك بانه في بدايه هذه الحرب كل
ساسه الغرب كانوا يستبعدون ان تكون هناك
ان يكون هناك تقديم لاسلحه غربيه وخاصه
وهنا سؤال
هذه الرساله بان واشنطن سترسل من يدرب
الطيارين على الاف سته عشر كيف تتلقاها
موسكو هل تتلقاها بانها اختبار للغرب هل
تتلقاها بانها رساله بانك لن تسقط هل هو
تحذير او هناك فعليا دخول للناتو على خط
هذه الحرب بطريقه فعليه مباشره
مشكله انا جاء صارت ناتجه ناتجه من حرب في
اوكرانيا
اهتمام ضخم كبير على صعيد العالمي لان
خطوره موجوده جديا استدام المباشر بين
قوات وامريكيه اولا وقوات الروسيه بكل
امكانيات الحربيه متوافره لديهم طبعا
خبراء الروسي يعتبرون ان امريكان لحتى
الان يشعرون تلك الحدود الذي يمكن ان
يتورطوا في هذا حرب ولكن كما انت ذكرتي
هناك كانت في البدايه الحرب موقف امريكي
واحد ان لا اي سلاح ثقيل لا اي سلاح
الهجوميه
متوسطه الماضي او
يعني خطير لتوصيل الحرب اثار الحرب اليوم
تغيرت الصوره تماما ولذلك نحن لا نعرف كيف
تتطور الاحداث غدا
لانه عندما كتب هذا المقال
او
ذكرى مئويه لميلاده هو كتب كلام سليمه ان
هناك لا يوجد خيار ثالث يا امريكان ينتشر
ويقدم هزيمه الى جيش روسي
يتفق على شروط الامريكيه بالقليل او
يجيد
المساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا ولكن موضوع
واحد
الطيرات 16 طبعا هذا المساله سيكون مشكله
المرحليه اذا يرسلوا السلاح وينه وينزل لا
يوجد كحس الخبراء الروس وهم يعرفون كل
المطارات اوكرانيه جيدا يعتبرون ان ليست
في اوكرانيا في اي مكان حتى في ضواحي كيف
المطارات مستعده ان يستقبلوا ان يقبلوا
الطائرات
ترسل واشنطن الطائرات ام لا هذا هو السؤال
هل حديث عن تدريب الطيارين هو فقط للتحذير
بالعوده الى التطورات الميدانيه الى ما
يحدث في باخموت دكتور عقيل خلينا نفهم من
حضرتك كيف تفكر اداره بايدن هل هذا
التصريح هو تحذير او هذا التصريح هو تمهيد
لامكانيه ارسال طائرات اف 16 فعليا حتى
وان كان المقابل اي روسيا ستفهم بان
الناتو دخل الى هذه اللعبه بطريقه مباشره
وفعليه
نعتقد ان هناك قرار امريكي
بالادارات
اعطيت في البدايه الموافقه لدول اوروبيه
الدنمارك تصور ان تعطي طائرات
موافقه من الولايات المتحده ثم تبعها
اعلان الرئيس بعيدا انا بتصوري انه اثقل
الغربيه بالقدره الاوكرانيه تزداد
والرغبه الغربيه بحسم هذا الصراع وعدم
تركه صراعا مفتوحا يستنزف القدرات ويهدد
امن اوروبا اعتقد هناك رغبه بانه ينهى هذا
الصراع بشكل من الاشكال بحل سلمي عندما
تكون اوكرانيا في وضع عسكري جيد جدا طبعا
هناك عرائق تقنيه
بخصوص لانه هذه ايضا تحتاج مطارات خاصه
هذه الطائره وتحتاج اطقم خاصه
لرعايتها والاوكرانيون يعني
كم عبر هذه الحرب اهوالها اعتقد سيتمكنون
من التكيف ولكن دكتور درجات نعم ولكن
السؤال مطروح لماذا الاب ستتعشر ولماذا في
هذا التوقيت بمعنى
الاف 16 لما نفكر فيها نفكر ونربطها بما
تحدثت عنه اوكرانيا عن هجومها المضاد اما
سيطرتها على المناطق التي احتلتها كما
تقول هي روسيا او كذلك وجود هجوم مضاد
عابر للحدود
تهدد به العمق الروسي
لماذا هذا الكلام في هذا التوقيت بالتحديد
هو ضغط سياسي على روسيا اننا دعم كامل
تقريبا يكاد يكون كاملا ومفتوحا هذا اولا
وهناك جانب استراتيجي عسكري اعتقد حتى مع
السرعه في التدريب وجود الطيارين
المناسبين واختصر برنامج التدريب هذه
الطائرات لن تدخل الخدمه اذا مضت كل
الاشياء بشكل ممتاز اعتقد لم تدخل في
الخدمه قبل نهايه الخريف الهجوم
الاوكرانيه ينبغي ان يحدث قبل هذا فاعتقد
هذان امران منفصل عن هناك جانب اخر مهم
يعني في هذه الحرب بقوه الجويه الاوكرانيه
هي قوه مح
دوده حقيقه ان ترد على القوه الجويه
الروسيه الكبيره والتي يعني اذت
الاوكرانيين كثيرا تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات
اف 16 تعني رغبه غربيه بان اوكرانيا تسيطر
على الجو بمقابل تعهدات اوكرانيه تبدو
واضحه وراسله واختبر الاوكرانيون في
تعهدات السابقه يعني اعطوها للغرب مقابل
اخذ الاسلحه واحترموا هذه التعهدات يعني
التعهدات هنا انه لا يستخدم هذا السلاح في
داخل روسيا وبتصور ليس من مصلحه
اوكرانيا ان تخرق تعهدها
هذا الغرب لانها ستف
قد حدها 29 دوله تقدم مختلف انواع الدعم
العصبي لماذا خساره هذا التحالف الضخم
يعني من
اجل هدف لن يفيد اوكرانيا كثيرا وهو
استهداف سلم الداخل من الجهه الروسيه سيد
فتشيس لطالما اعتبرت روسيا بان هناك خطوط
حمراء لهذه الحرب او خطوط حمراء لتزويد
الغرب كيف بالاسلحه ومن بين هذه الخطوط
الحمراء هي الاف 16 هل يمكن الحديث عن
سقوط هذا الخط الاحمر وبالتالي قد نكون في
مواجهه
روسيه مع الغرب تكون ارضها القرم
انا اعتبر ان كل الاحاديث حول خطوط
الحمراء هذا نظريا
بالعمل في الميدان هناك خطوط اخرى حسب
التطور وتطوير الاحداث في ميدان وفي وجود
الاسلحه الفلانيه من جهتين لذلك تكتيك
تتغير يوميا اذا بيرسلات
16 وين سيكون مطار الاقامه مطار الاقامه
في بولونيا يجب الطائرات 16 من مطار
بولونيا هذا مطار بولوني تتحول الى
هدف الشرعي لقوات مصالح الروسيه هذا الخير
في شمال الاتوسي هذا ما بده ياهو حلف لذلك
امريكا لا تقدم المساعدات
اوكرانيا ليست فيها مطارات قادره ان تهبط
فيها الاف سته عشر ما الذي يفرق بين
المطارات القادره على استقرار نفسه عشر
والمطارات التي تستقبل كل يوم سخوي والماج
وكل طائرات العسكريه الاخرى
صحيح ولكن هذا انا ارجو فقط خبراء في مجال
الطيران هم يعتبرون ان كل المطارات حربيه
موجوده حاليا في اوكرانيا مش صالحه لقبول
16 هو يطلب
مطارات خاصه مدرج خاص وكذلك هناك نقطه
اخرى كل طائره من هذا النوع تحتاجه
بالعنايه تكنيكيه وهناك طبعا يمكن ان يحضر
يدرب بعض تكنيكيين في المانيا وفي هولندا
في اي دوله حلف شمال الاطلسي اخرى ولكن مش
صدفه امريكا لا تقدم السيارات اف 16
لاوكرانيا يطلب هذا التقديم من دول
اوروبيه وهذا مشكله علاقات بين اوروبا
وامريكا ليست مشكله علاقات بين روسيا
وامريكا وهنا مواضيع عديده
ليس العسكريه مواضيع سياسيه
الاعلاميه نفسيه حرب بكل اشكالها ولذلك
انا اتصور انه امريكا لا تقدم في نهايه
المطاف اي طائره امريكيه الى الى حتى شروط
كانت يرخص تقديم طيرات المانيه يعني
بريطانيه الى الى اوكرانيا شرطا ان لا
تداخل عمق الروسي كان يفهمون
لا يحب هناك استثناء
نحن نتحدث عنه
روسيا مش نايمه روسيا كذلك يقوي ويدرس
وياخذ الدروس اخذ الدروس من حايمرس ناجح
حامر في مرحله الاولى وين اليوم حايمرز
سقطوا شيء سيكون مع الطائرات مع الاب ستسق
التجربه السلاح الامريكي وروسي وضحت هذه
النقطه ولكن مختبر بما اننا نتحدث عن
الوعود ومنذ قليل دكتور عقيل قال بانه كيف
التزمت وجربها الغرب في مقابل لي التزمات
ووفت بوعودها بخصوص عدم استعمال هذه
الاسلحه باتجاه العمق الروسي ولكن كان
هناك تسريبات بانه هناك استثناء لجزيره
القرم هل يمكن ان تستعمل هذه الطائرات
باتجاه القرم
دكتور عقيل
تواصل الى غير ملابس ساعود خليني فقط افهم
وجهه نظر الامريكيه مع دكتور عقيل يعني
الذي الذي رشح في الاعلام من مص
ادر انه الاستثناء الوحيد يتعلق بداخل
الاراضي الروسيه لا تستخدم الاسلحه
الامريكيه والغربيه اسلحه عموما في داخل
الاراضي الروسيه ومن ضمنها طائره اف 16
الاستخدامها في القرن ولهذا سالت ولهذا
سالت عن جزيره القرم دكتور عقيل لانه
جزيره القرم اوكرانيا تعتبرها اوكرانيا
روسيا تعتبرها بانه من 2014 روسيه
فلما نتحدث عن العمق الروسي هل نتحدث عن
القرم نتحدث بلا القرم القرم ستكون ساحه
لهذه المواجهات
الولايات المتحده الغرب الناتو معظم
المجتمع الدولي يعتبر القرن والدومباس جزء
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه الالحاق الروسي لها
ليس له اثر قانوني هو فعل امر واقع
واستخدمت اسلحه اوكرانيه صواريخ منحتها
الولايات المتحده لاوكرانيا استخدمت في
على باستهداف اهداف روسيه في داخل جزيره
القرم يعني مرتين او ثلاثه من ضمنها ضرب
سكه القطار فاعتقد لا يوجد اي استثناء
وضحت هذه النقطه في دقيقه
اذا استعملت الاب ستتعشر باتجاه جزيره
القرم هل ستعتبر روسيا هذا
تجاوزا واستهدافا لعمقها الروسي
عباس الخبير في شؤون السياسيه الامريكيه
شكرا لكما السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات